so forgive me
i'm not actually like that knowledgeable
about the history of attempts of
building social networks to solve the
problem the year solving
but i was made aware that there was an
app
app or at least a social network called
yik yak
that was had a similar kind of
focus i think the thing you've spoken
about
that differs between librex and yikayak
is that
yike was defined am i pronouncing it
right even
uh you're good i'm good i met the
founder so i can confirm okay you can
confirm cool
uh the that it was constrained to a
geographical area versus like
to the actual community um and that
and that somehow had fundamental like
actual
differences in social dynamics that
resulted but
can you speak to the history of yik yak
like how does lee breaks differ
what lessons have you learned from that
oh and i should say that i guess there
was controversial
i don't know i didn't look at the
details but i'm guessing there's a bunch
of racism and hate speech and all that
kind of stuff that emerges there was
on you okay so that's an example of like
okay here's how it goes wrong when you
have an anonymity
on college campuses so how does he
breaks going to do better
yeah you got a lot of problems content
problems but the content problems go
deeper than
maybe what the press would reveal
there's a lot to say and
part of it is parsing exactly what to
talk about when it comes to
and when you talk about startups i mean
you know this i i
you know startups um and you look at the
postmortem it's almost
never what people think it is and and
oftentimes these things are
somewhat unknowable and the the degree
to which people
seeking confirmation bias to something
seeking closure yes
look to find a singular attribute that
caused the failure
it feels like the little details often
make all the difference
yes and i think i think the details are
so little that as humans
we are not capable of parsing even what
they are
but i'll tell you i'll tell you my
perspective on it
um knowing that i am also a human with
biases um
in this particular case very significant
biases yeah
yeah um i um
so i started building librex for its own
merits i i i
at first i wasn't aware of yik yak but
as i started to talk to people about
this platform i was building i i was
made aware of the cac and i
built it from day one with a lot of the
issues you get had in mind the
so as you said the one difference
between yak is the geographical versus
community-based aspect going along with
that
one thing i realized by researching
social media sites is that
the majority of the negative content the
content that's
terrible and breaking all the rules is
created by
really and the people who are not
reformable
so to speak the people who are not
showing the best part of
the human yeah experience yeah um
it's a really small minority right yeah
i remember
i was listening to the founder of 4chan
moot talk about this how like
one guy was able to basically destroy
like large swaths of his community
yeah that's part of what makes it
exciting for that minority
is how much power they can have so if if
you're predisposed to think in this way
it's exciting that you can walk into
like i mentioned the party before you
have a party of a lot of positive people
and it feels especially if you
don't have much power in this world it
feels exceptionally empowering
to just uh to destroy
like the lives of many yeah and if you
think this way
it's a problem but i i i i'm hopeful
that you're right that in most cases
it's going to be a minority of people i
think it is
and that's what the research has showed
and one
really powerful thing is that we can
really
actively control who comes in and out of
our community based on the
edu verification and we can also control
who's not in our community because we
have that lever where each account is
associated with it.edu
so that's the first point i would put
out point out there second point is
controlled expansion meaning that we
have community moderation
we have this panel that allows the
moderators to see
all of the highly downvoted content
all of the reported content all the
flagged content and look through it
and decide what they like and what's
appropriate and what's not appropriate
and we have um we ping every moderator
when there's a report so things are
taken down pretty quickly and we have
our standards and we have
i think above all of that we have a
mission and
it's a community-based mission yukek was
more of a fun app and
by its own admission it was a place
where people could enjoy themselves and
could sort of yak yeah
yeah you know chit chat um we have a we
have a bigger purpose than that
frankly and i think i think that shows
and the people who self-select to be on
that app
to be on librex and to be on yik yak
respectively the last thing i'll say is
yuk yak was very few characters it was a
twitter-esque platform
and that doesn't allow for a tremendous
amount of nuance it doesn't allow for a
tremendous amount of conversation
um librex is much more long form and so
the kind of
um posts that you'll get on librex are
can spam pages
they're like what people are starting to
realize
is that they can reach a lot more people
at a lot more pertinent of a time
a lot more quickly by posting their
thoughts on librex than if they went to
their school newspaper
and i think the school newspapers might
be a little worried about that but more
importantly we're connecting people in
this way we're
long-form communication with nuance that
takes into account everything that's
happening in the community
temporally is really
available at librex and you know not
really
communicable in 240 or 480 or whatever
the number of characters
the acts were bound to and then you know
i could talk about the history of
the act if you want me to go further um
they
started i think they were at 12 schools
and then
spring break it people told their
friends
look at this app a thousand schools
signed up and were had active
communities they had a problem on their
hands i see and then the high schools
come on board
yeah i think a lot of the things you
said uh ring true to me
but especially the vision one which i do
think uh having a vision
in the leadership having a mission makes
all the difference in the world
now that that's both for the engineers
that are building
like the team that's building the app
the moderation and
users because they kind of the mission
carries itself
uh through the behavior of the
of the people on the social network
you